Shack is there a player in our era that  you played against where Joker's game is  similar to someone you faced with that  size being able to handle the basketball  can face you up and knock down threes  can play with this back to the basket  because our player that you faced that  was similar to the yogic if you remember  earlier on when I first got in the  league I was scared of your seven god by  the name of Rik Smits and similar the  ribs mix not a lot of athleticism but  real crafty around the basket very soft  lighting no blood was terrible he was  hard to guard Brad Miller is another  name that he's stop stop big countries  on that list to the slowest Sean Bradley  I appreciate it guys all right